AICan is an opportunity
to bring our researchers together
from across the AI institutes
and really across the country,
to share their ideas,
to get to know each other,
and to look for new opportunities
for collaboration.
My name is Nicolas Papernot
I'm an assistant professor
at the University of Toronto and a Canada
CIFAR AI Chair at the Vector Institute.
My research group studies
the security and privacy
of machine learning,
which is essentially trying
to get us to a point
where we as end users, as a society,
we can trust AI systems
to make predictions that are correct
and also to make these predictions
without relying
too much on sensitive data.
My name is Golnoosh Farnadi,
and I am an assistant
professor at McGill University.
I have an adjunct position
at the University of Montreal
Core academic membership at Mila
and am one of the CIFAR AI Chairholders.
From 2017
I started working on this new field,
which is called algorithmic fairness.
The goal is just like
people are realizing that
just focusing on one aspect,
which is just performance
should not be enough.
We should also think about
the different biases in the systems,
for different demographics,
for example, for female versus male,
maybe the results of the
models are different,
so maybe you want to do something
about it.
And that's
kind of like the question
I started thinking about, like,
can we actually trust the systems?
We decided to hold
AICan this year in St. John’s,
at the advice
of our National Program Committee,
this is a group of chairs
who help us to
plan our events and activities
so that they really meet the needs
and the desires of the Canada
CIFAR AI Chairs community.
The Canada CIFAR AI Chairs
are really some of the top
AI researchers in the world.
There are more than 120 researchers
that we have
either attracted or kept in Canada
through this program.
We're really taking the time
to reflect together as a group,
what we're trying to achieve
as a community of researchers
working on AI in Canada.
Having the Chairs
together to talk about
our responsibilities
as researchers, to deliver
AI that is delivering
positive social impact for society.
Where is it that we as researchers
can work together
to help to inform and guide policy?
How can we work with our partners
in different sectors in the government
to make sure that Canada is developing
AI that is really delivering
positive social benefits.